Peggy's 16 hey everyone it's Dan ma here
once again joined by battlefield expert
study thank you for joining me
hello there this time we're going to be
looking at recon and support
specifically the weapons the sidearms
and the gadgets that marry well to these
various combat roles
so first up we are looking at recon and
specifically Pathfinder so first of all
tell us about the the primary weapon and
and why you've opted for that so the
smle has a 10 round magazine which is
the most in the game it's got a fast
fire rate and it's got a medium scope on
it so you know it's got a three time
scope on it which is very close range
and with the specializations I've gone
for quicker aim-down-sight I've gone for
faster switching weapons so that you can
switch to your pistol in order to fight
enemies at close range and it also
reboots the sniper faster so but be at
your rate of fire with the sniper rifle
is also much faster so the Ruby sidearm
is one of the fastest firing pistols you
go through a magazine very fast not very
accurate but it's very good finishing
off enemies that you've already hit with
your sniper rifle so the smle has
reasonably low damage for a sniper rifle
but if you do hit someone at close range
you can quickly switch to your Ruby
using a specialization they get alerted
to try and charge at you in the usual
rattle off a few shots of the handgun
and job done yeah that's right what
gadgets do tend to arm your Pathfinder
with because obviously you want to be a
bit more stealthy if you want to be
pushing the enemy's spawns you might
want to take the smoke but I'd take the
infantry grenade because obviously what
you can ask to do is throw the grenade
where the enemies are
and then shoot the grenade with the
sniper rifle to instantly do the damage
before they can run away and finally in
this loadout we've got the all-important
spawn beacon yes so most important in
this class setup is the spawn beacon
it's basically useless without the spawn
beacon so you have to make sure that
you're using this as much as you can
whenever it goes down because it lasts
between lives so you can put it down and
you can respawn several times and as
long as no one finds it it will stay
static in the world to make sure that
your squad always has a flank
all right so moving on we've got a
sniper class study tell me why you've
gone for this particular weapon so the
must-have weapon of choice is the car 98
and the reason for that is it has the
fastest bullet velocity in the game so
you're going for the long range scope
the six times scope it's a lot easier to
hit moving targets a lot easier to hit
headshots and the specializations I've
chosen are fast rating down site so you
can acquire your targets quicker
variable suit zooming so it allows you
to change the zeroing of the scope for
people who are slightly further away
that you need to adjust your zeroing for
low-drag rounds which means that the
bullets will travel even faster than the
normal will drop and then you can go for
the bipod as well which means that you
can rest it on a surface and you won't
actually need to hold your breath when
rome's the bipod we haven't discussed
the the your sidearm either what's your
sidearm of choice with this one so with
this one similar to the m1911 it's the
p38 it has nine rounds a slower rate of
fire but it does more damage at longer
ranges and then because you're playing a
passive role I always thought the smoke
grenade would be the best thing to use
because a little bit time if you're out
further away from the battle the things
that are going to annoy you most other
vehicles so being able to cover your
tracks if you start getting shot at by a
plane or a tank or another sniper if you
need to he'll throw down your smoke
grenade run away off into the bushes
heal yourself and then go back out to
another location
so now we move over to the support class
first up we're going to look at the the
engineer so the support class is more of
a medium long range class but with the
engineer class I went for the shotgun
so the drilling shotgun this plays
multiple roles because it has two
different fire modes the first being a
rifle round almost like a sniper and
then you can switch the fire mode to the
buckshot and then the buckshot can
finish them off after you've hit them at
range with that right that's the high
spread close range shotgun that we're
all used to but it's very versatile at
medium and long range and close range it
does everything so in the
specializations I've gone for an
improved trigger which means I can fire
off all three barrels as quickly as
possible
heavier buckshot which means it has a
longer lethal range and also penetrating
shot which means that it can actually
hit multiple targets and then I've gone
for the internal choke which means that
the tightness of the reticule when
you're aiming the choke means that more
of the pellets go where you're aiming
you're gonna want to default to your
sidearm fairly frequently I imagine
especially with that long reload you
don't want to have to rely on trying to
reload halfway through the fight if the
person that you shot at is still alive
so you'd fire off all three of your
barrels and then as a last resort try
and use the pistol to finish off
whatever the hell that they have left
after being shot at by the the two heavy
barrels what are your recommendations
for the engineers gadgets
so the engineer has access to the sticky
grenade which means that you throw it on
the ground and wherever it lands or
whether it's on the ground or on a
vehicle it will then stick to that
immediately I've also gone for the
placeable ammo the ammo box it's much
more passive so what you can do is
whilst you on your tank you see some
people that need some ammo you're not
going to go out and give it every one
manually pouches you drop the Box on the
floor and say let get your own about
yourselves
yeah help yourselves I'm gonna go off on
this tank and then I've also gone for
the 80 mine as well you're just gonna
want to be placing the 80 mines in
high-traffic areas just in case one of
those vehicles just happens to drive
over it because they're very hard to see
you know the engineer class in previous
battlefields is more of a close range
didn't very passive but this class you
can actually be good at all ranges and
you can be aggressive and it's really
useful
and so we come to the final combat role
this is the machine gunner what is it
that makes the machine gunner so fun to
use
so I've gone for the FG 42 it's actually
much more of a high damage high rate of
fire something to compete with the
assault rifles or you can bipod it and
actually hit people very far away with
accurate fire and with this class with
the specializations I've gone for faster
aim-down-sight so you can compete with
those assault rifles I've gone for more
accurate fire while stationary less
horizontal recoil because that's the
hardest one to control and then also
moving 60% faster whilst aiming down
down the sights because I mean
ultimately you're still at support class
so that added mobility is still going to
be very very important yeah and
alongside that what's your what's your
sidearm pick so I've gone for the m1911
so it's a medium range a medium range
pistol for finishing off enemies that
you've potentially hit and so we we move
into the gadgets yeah so with this one
we've dropped the sticky grenades we can
that's more for vehicles takes a little
bit long to explode and we've gone for
the impact neighs and as soon as it hits
the ground within one second that
explodes you're shooting some enemies
they run behind cover you just chunk
that straight away they have no time to
heal it's it's really good for finishing
off enemies that have taken damage so we
haven't gone for the ammo box this time
we've gone for the ammo pouches so this
means that you're just your resupplying
ammo when you see the enemies it's much
much less passive you have to be very
aware of the players that need ammo but
you can be aggressive and you can keep
giving Emma so the final gadget that
I've chosen for this class is the 80
grenade pistol it's almost like a mini
RPG yeah
and it's useful versus infantry and
tanks the machine gunner is such a
versatile class because it basically
allows you to choose whether you want to
be aggressive or and can be very
defensive and hold a position and bipod
up and then have full accuracy whilst in
full automatic fire would you advise
that people still experiment and and see
which weapons actually fit their
playstyle better you just have to kind
of
mix and match and see how aggressive or
passive you actually play and then
decide that whether those different
stats actually will help you in that
regard well that is it for our in-depth
guide to the the weapons and gadgets
that will benefit you when you finally
play battlefield 5 that was obviously
the support and recon classes but if you
want to find out more about how to get
the most out of the assault and medic
classes and combat roles make sure you
go and check out our earlier video thank
you very much for watching plate on the
world's most powerful console
[Music]